1 e
un momento de meditación en un contexto
de extrema tensión
muchos aquí perdieron a un familiar en
el levantamiento de maidán de 2014
presente en el homenaje el expresidente
petro poroshenko elegido tras ese
acontecimiento histórico apenas puede
creer que su país siga estando amenazado
creo que putin se ha vuelto
completamente loco esta es una fecha
simbólica para ucrania y después de ocho
años de conflicto corremos un gran
peligro por la incesante presión de
putin hoy estamos rodeados por el
ejército ruso
después de la misa juliá hace los
últimos preparativos para una marcha en
honor a los desaparecidos entre ellos
estaba su marido que murió tras ser
golpeado hasta la muerte
los ucranianos tienen buena memoria si
es necesario nos enfrentaremos al
agresor y este es rusia no lo
olvidaremos
cientos de manifestantes se dirigen a la
plaza de la independencia donde todo
comenzó
mientras que en kiev al y cada vez que
vuelve a la plaza de maidán símbolo de
resistencia para los ucranianos piensa
en los momentos vividos
primero fueron los días que pasaron
ayudando a los heridos de bala antes de
ir a luchar en el frente
nuestro trabajo era atender a los
heridos que estaban cubiertos de sangre
se retorcían de dolor
estoy listo para unirme a las fuerzas
armadas de nuevo ya ha averiguado a
dónde tengo que ir para ser desplegado
en el frente y allí sabré exactamente
qué hacer
[Música]
a pesar de las repetidas declaraciones
alarmistas de washington sobre una
posible invasión rusa los ucranianos no
están dispuestos a dejarse intimidar
según una encuesta reciente mientras que
el 60% de la población quiere que su
país entre en la otan